the virus is spreading rapidly in every
corner
of our city we'll soon reach an average
of 100 cases per 100 000 people
with a significant number of boroughs
already
over that threshold hospital admissions
are up more patients are going to
intensive care units
and sadly the number of londoners dying
every day
is increasing again it's my expectation
that the government will today announce
that london
will shortly be moving into tier two or
the high
alert level of restrictions i've had a
meeting this morning
with the secretary of state for health
and mhclg
as well as london leaders and scientific
advisors
final conversations with ministers are
ongoing around this as we meet
but i expect ministers to make an
announcement to parliament later
this morning this move is based on the
expert public health
and scientific advice about what is
necessary
to save lives in the capital in addition
to the restrictions already in place
this would mean different households in
london not been able to mix indoors
nobody wants to see more restrictions
but this is deemed to be necessary in
order to protect londoners
by myself london council leaders and by
ministers
as part of our discussions i've also
made clear to the government
that we need more flash support for
london's businesses
workers and public services as we face
more restrictions
and i'll continue to make this case
given how far the virus has already been
allowed to spread
and given the government's complete
failure to get a working test
trace and isolate system in place i
believe
we also need action on a national scale
just as the government's own
scientific advisors have recommended
that's why
i'll continue to call for a short
national
circuit breaker this could save
thousands of lives
drive the virus down to manageable
levels and give the government more time
to finally get a grip on its failing
test
and trace system in london
we experienced the worst of kobe 19 back
in the spring thousands of lives were
lost
and our economy has been left reeling
we simply can't afford for the
government to be slow to act
again the supposed choice
between saving the economy and saving
lives
between restrictions and freedoms is
an entirely false one because the later
we take the necessary steps to slow the
spread of the virus
the more severe these steps will have to
be and the longer
they'll have to last in order to drive
down
infection rates no matter how much
some people want to pretend otherwise
and bury their heads in the sand
the truth is that the health crisis and
the economic
crisis are inextricably linked
that's why getting the virus under
control is the only way we can both
protect
lives and our economy there's simply
no other option i must warn londoners
that we've got a difficult winter ahead
but just as we've always done throughout
our city's great history
i know we'll get through this dark time
by pulling
together so i urge all londoners to
continue to follow the rules
so we can support our nhs save lives
and protect our economy